قال الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني
رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الاقتصاد البلاده حقق هذا افضل مقارنه
بالاقتصادات العالميه وقال في مقابله على
تلفزيون قطر ان هذا الاداء يظهر القطري
ليس بالاقتصاد الهاشمي ولا الضعيف
اذا احنا قارنا اداء الاقتصاد القطري
بالاداء العالمي الحمد لله اداءنا دائما
كان افضل سواء كان من معدلات التضخم يعني
صندوق النقد الدولي يطلع تقرير العام
الماضي التضخم العالمي كان ثمانيه فاصله
ثمانيه في المئه بينما قطر تقريبا كانت
عند الخمسه في المئه يعني
ودائما لو تلاحظ تشوف
معدل مستويات التضخم مثلا قاعده تصير في
العالم دائما دوله قطر اقل من المتوسط
العالمي وهذا يعتبر ايضا يعتبر يعني كعداء
اقتصادي جيد ومبين انه يعني ليس بالاقتصاد
الهشه والاقتصاد
وقال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري ان صندوق ثروه السياديه سيكون
بمثابه بئر نفط جديده عندما ينتهي النفط
والغاز على حد قوله مشيرا الى ان الجهاز
يستثمر داخليا لملئ فجوات النشاط
الاقتصادي ويستثمر خارجيا على اساس تجاريا
بحث وانه اثبت جداره بين صناديق الثروه
السياديه الدوليه الاقدم
جهاز غدا واستثمار ترى يستثمر الداخليا
وخارجيا يعني
وين مهمته هو في الاقتصاد الداخلي هو
مهمته ملا فجوه تكون في الاقتصاد لا يزال
القطاع الخاص غير
يعني مستعد انه يستثمر فيها وهنا يجي دور
الجهاز خطر الاستثمار انه يملي هذا الفجوه
الى انه يصير في قطاع يعني قوي في هذا
المجال والقطاع الخاص يكون عنده الاستعداد
وعنده القابليه هنا جهاز قطر استماره يجب
ان يتراجع دوله عشره ان ما يكون منافس
للقطاع الخاص وهذا اللي احنا نطمح فيه
اما الاستثمارات الخارجيه فهي كلها مبنيه
على قرارات تجاريه بحته اكيد ان الاستثمار
في مربح وفي خاسر ولكن احنا اذا نتكلم على
الحصيله محصله الصندوق الحمد لله ادائه
فوق الممتاز وينافس صناديق صناديق كبيره
يعني موجوده